here's one thing we had a little bit of
[ __ ] i'm talking about we had a break
i learned something new about you the
other day
what is it are you listening i always
listen to you
i learned something new about you that
kind of gave me a little bit of closure
and a little bit of like more of an
understanding for you
and it's like you know earlier you're
like i'm really generous right and you
are in terms of giving things and
experiences for people like
you are the most generous person i've
ever met but you have almost an
inability to offer like physical
affection and we talked about this
and it was like how did your parents
like reaffirm or show you love when you
were younger and you were like they were
very good at saying i love you
which i am you're very good with words
of affirmation yeah you're very good
with showing like show not not not acts
of service but like buying things
that's sad yeah right
money money is a way of showing love
yeah but
oh my god i did this one thing
i keep thinking about what
oh
god i've never wanted to talk about this
let me say one more thing though yeah go
ahead but you do not know how to receive
touch
go ahead
reception cleared
that was hot and i asked him i was like
what does this feel like because i was
like rubbing his back and he was like it
feels fine like it's just it feels fine
and i was like no tell me what this
really feels like he's like it's okay
because growing up to me the the only
kind of physical affection i got was
either violence right or like
the extreme of like kiss me on the lips
oh i see my dad would be like
that's what you're good at you like
giving random like hard kisses right so
it's like then you you go i had to kiss
my dad
she tighten up your lips like this
like that because if you try to like run
your hair
on his like if i when we were at bed at
night and i try to like touch him or
anything like that it's like he recoils
so like he like moves backwards
that's so nice
that's loving or when he's sick and i'm
like let me take care of you that's like
that's something i will defend for the
rest of my [ __ ] life young lady all
right
it's just that when i'm sick
when i was a kid right
and i'd be like i'm sick and they'll be
like okay i'll be like i'll see you in
three days
i respect it and i lock the door in my
bedroom and i just [ __ ] weather the
storm i respect that i don't need
massages i don't need soup from you i
don't need echinacea or you know vitamin
c or anything all right or zinc tablets
no i'll do it on my own what i do is old
school
i'll go and i'll go to a vaughn's and
i'll buy cloves of garlic
stick it up your butt yes
i've got a [ __ ] animal
with you today
you weren't damn [ __ ] cloves of
garlic in my butthole baby oh man
god what are you dracula
[Laughter]
is that dracula do you think no it's not
a guy
like a turkey or something yeah
no but what i do is i take cloves of
garlic right i peel them obviously and i
chew them raw
that's hard and does that work i don't
know if it does but i feel like yeah so
i'll do like 10 cloves of garlic
raw and it burns your insides
right and then i'll just
put the sheet over my head
lay in the bed
and just write it out
mm-hmm yeah i'm on that same day oh
you're not you're mrs
i'm sick can you make me something so
when she does that do you
he doesn't know how oh i don't know how
he doesn't know
in fact besides popo besides hard
purpose he doesn't know look watch him
ask him ask him to give me a hug right
now hey do you mind hugging clown see he
closes his eyes and he goes oh i guess
he's shooting for a double
he's going for a double or a single leg
yeah when the japanese you know i mean
we're coming down in pearl harbor they
were closing under their eyes as well
yeah it's like a death for him
we're watching a movie
let's write and then say
what
[Laughter]
oh man that's nice
it's so nice oh my god i just felt it
thank you so much for that that's so
nice
you know what it it uh
it's like your soul is getting massaged
or something you know in the beginning
when we first started this podcast like
years ago he would always say
ah you know what i love about kalila
is that after sex she would just like
roll over and not want affection and
she'd get on her phone that couldn't
have been farther from the truth no that
you're like that but baby you're so
[ __ ] like that
you're so [ __ ] like that i can't even
believe you're saying this out loud
right now telling the truth
baby you know what i was like that i
wanted to keep you so badly and this is
the one thing you said i don't cuddle i
don't like that stuff
and so i was like i want to stay in this
relationship i want him to like me so
much so i'm going to play the cool girl
and so after sex i would just be like